technology is an embodiment of human
creativity and imagination an extension
of the human mind that later transforms
the human mind as philosopher Marshall
McLuhan wrote we build the tools and
then the tools build us disrupting the
status quo and opening up a new
possibility space for human enterprise
we use our technology to actualize our
imagination to extrude our dreams into
existence and technology's relentless
pace of change requires a new kind of
understanding a new kind of mindset
because technological change is
exponential whereby human intuition
about change is linear the co-founder of
Intel Gordon Moore was a visionary
thinker who first identified the
exponential nature of technological
progress now today I'm thrilled to sit
down with Genevieve Bell talk about the
future of tech and Intel innovation
Genevieve can you tell me how you see
the next 50 years of innovation powered
by Intel changing the world what happens
when we have 5g ubiquitous connectivity
what happens when we have self-driving
automobiles everywhere what happens when
all these technologies artificial
intelligence quantum computing
harnessing the strangeness of quantum
physics to make massively more powerful
computers I mean are we heading towards
the transformation of humanity I think
we have to be all right I mean if you
look at the first 50 years of Moore's
Loren of Intel that was a company that
was about how did we take incredibly
basic technology and build computing on
top of that computing was pretty simple
just basically desktop computers and
laptop computers and more recently a
little bit of servers but if you look at
the next 50 years we're talking about
the power of computing in everything
whether it means making a very flat
world come alive with technology think
about what is the Internet of Things
look like when it's every object made
smart when it's every object animated
when it's not just about how do you
connect all those objects but what would
happen when you did for me the
possibilities they're kind of amazing
right not only are we talking about a
completely different lived experience we
also actually have to think differently
about how would we measure our success
what would it look like to make all of
that one it's not just
about scaling and density but what are
we gonna care about as humans how will
we know it's a world we want to live in
how we regulate it well it raises all
kinds of fascinating questions but also
opens up a whole new space for
creativity and play and you talk about
the Internet of Things and this idea
that we're making more powerful sensors
that are smaller all the time and so
essentially we're gonna infuse the
entire world with intelligence with AI
so we'll have objects that give us
real-time feedback you know Kevin Kelley
talks about cognate izing the world the
same way we electrified it with
electricity so is this a kind of
technically technologically enabled
animism or everyday objects will be
alive and will talk to us so it's a kind
of a return to an earlier form of
consciousness when everything was alive
listen I think there'll be a form of
magical thinking where we imagine that
everything is alive and that everything
has a point of view about it when I
certainly remember consumers telling me
when I ot first came a long wait and you
telling me that thing is gossiping about
me because we imagine that everything
everything was powered by data if
everything had a capacity to be smart
that it would also have opinions about
us and that that would feel weird so I
do think there's a piece where it's
taken us a little while to adjust to a
world of even just mobile phones in the
internet mhm
well we control those things but
imagining a world where the data is
circulating machine-to-machine sometimes
with us not in the loop it's an
interesting world to imagine what it
would be to be human in that case but it
also requires thinking about an
incredibly different landscape of
Technology you know it might sound like
a bumper sticker to repeat this phrase
but hearing you talk and thinking about
the future makes me think of arthur c
clarke snow ssin that any sufficiently
advanced technology is indistinguishable
from magic I mean we're talking about
Riaan chanting the world and fusing
intelligence into everyday objects I
mean cars that drive themselves which
were already seeing I mean it's the
stuff of dreams and it's becoming real
so I want to thank you for sharing your
insights for Intel's 50th it's
absolutely my pleasure